[Music]
so you're gonna save the solar system
with the staff wielding talents of the
hunter class in destiny - not only did
you pick a well-rounded savior skilled
in gunplay and melee combat you're also
gonna look awesome when you rack up
those kill counts the base abilities and
power of your super can take you far but
we have tips on how to make the most of
this crafty and agile class after we've
helped you transform into a hunter
savant be sure to give us a like and
subscribe to our youtube channel for all
your other destiny - guides and tips
needs let's get started every hunter
subclass is qualified to be a useful
contributor no matter the mode stick
with your starting subclass the Ark
Strider if you like to take the fight to
the enemy as its hands down the best
melee fighter if you're not the
up-close-and-personal type but still
enjoy the rush of racking up a body
count the ranged weapon prowess of the
gunslinger offers a wealth of abilities
tailored for shooter fans if you're less
of a glory seeker the nightstalker
subclass has a number of non-lethal yet
highly effective abilities that subdues
enemies making them easy targets for
nearby Guardians
for hunters movement is king once you
start taking on quests on earth practice
jumping into the fray and fatally
punching enemies in quick succession
become accustomed to rushing quickly
into crowds and getting out once your
health goes critical
while the hunter doesn't have a
traditional midair power slam you can
still be an effective killer from the
skies by coming down from a double or
triple jump with a melee blow what makes
the hunter the most agile class arts to
dodge abilities if you're very
comfortable melee combat or a sticking
with the arc Strider the gamblers dodge
is the way to go since it recharges your
melee ability the marksman dodge is more
suited to hunters who lead toward ranged
weapons as it quickly reloads your armed
weapon next chain the arc staff it's one
of the most user-friendly supers in
destiny - allowing you to whale on
nearby enemies well you can do a lot of
damage by relying on the powerful slab
from the air you'd be missing out on the
arc staffs lethal nuances since the
super uses both the melee and ranged
weapon buttons you can experiment with
different combinations by using both
inputs in the string of attacks
if after spending a few hours with the
arc Strider you find yourself more
comfortable with ranged combat switch to
the gunslinger after you've unlocked the
subclass if you're good at precision
kills you're missing out if you're not
unlocking the way of the Sharpshooter
passive abilities all of which reward
your Deadeye talents what complements
your skills as a sharpshooter are the
area effect benefits of the incendiary
grenade combine these with the deadly
throwing knives using either passive
ability paths with great gun-slinging
comes great responsibility with your
golden gun a single shot from the supers
potent too bad you only have three
rounds before recharging it goes without
saying that you need to pick your
targets carefully this doesn't diminish
the value of the gunslinger though half
of the subclasses eight passive
abilities are designed to enhance the
super whether it's improved accuracy
doubling your ammo or increased damage
now unto the hunter Nightstalker against
the AI it's an excellent support player
but it's also self sufficient when you
find yourself isolated use vanish and
smoke to create an invisibility cloud
for you and your nearby allies it's also
easy to take the fight to the AI which
is why you should prioritize swarm and
incendiary grenades over the trip mind
grenade conversely you can surprise
opponents in the crucible with traps
like the tripmine and the snare bomb
speaking of PvP the Night Stalker can be
a huge contributor defensively and
offensively especially when using
vanishing step to disappear and keen
scout to boost sprinting last but not
least look for armor that enhances
sprinting and sliding both of which go a
long way and making you hard to kill
this leads us to the shadow shot super
on its own the super isn't lethal but it
restricts your foes movements and
abilities making them vulnerable to your
friends in your own follow-up attacks
whether alone or in a group the true
power of the shadow shot is harnessed
through your passive abilities under the
way of the trapper you can enhance the
super with deadfall which unleashes void
anchor traps when choosing way of the
pathfinder the möbius quiver can
transform the shadow shot into a
damage-dealing super part of the pack
which conjures orbs of light as you kill
underscores the supers usefulness
against multiple enemies as opposed to a
single boss
last but not least don't get mail a
cocky combination blow one of the way of
the warrior passive abilities triggers
health regeneration and increases melee
damage and this boost can feel
empowering but you're not invincible it
can be easy to get caught in a killing
spree and ignore your low health this
also applies to the arc staff just
because you have the superhuman ability
to disintegrate your foes doesn't mean
you're impervious to attacks especially
when your staff can't reach far-off
enemies
and those are our tips for hunter
optimization the beauty of destiny 2 is
that there will be countless raids
strikes and other post story skirmishes
to hone your hunter skills we encourage
you to give each subclass a shot you
might be surprised what you'll discover
after spending a dozen hours of the
Night Stalker even if you're more
comfortable with say the arc Strider
thanks for watching